[Música]
y millones fueron separados de su hijo o
hija padre o madre hermano o hermana a
causa de la guerra de korea cuando una
parte de la familia quedó en territorio
norcoreano mientras que la otra llevó
una vida muy diferente en el sur debido
a unas 20 sesiones de reunión que se han
organizado desde el 2000 varias familias
se han reencontrado por primera vez
desde la separación de las dos coreas
durante algunas horas conmovedoras los
seres queridos pudieron después de
décadas de silencio o conversar
abrazarse reír y sobre todo llorar por
la cruel división que les impidió
compartir sus vidas esta guerra que hace
siete décadas dejó millones de víctimas
mortales puede parecer lejana pero para
las dos coreas está muy viva porque los
restos de miles de soldados fueron
abandonados surcoreanos norcoreanos pero
también chinos estadounidenses y
franceses más de 10 países participaron
de este conflicto nuestros reporteros
fueron testigos de una investigación sin
precedentes de seúl para encontrar los
cuerpos de los soldados caídos los
invito a ver este boleto de vuelo
a la guerra de corea
[Música]
es una ceremonia que esperaron durante
70 años cuatro soldados surcoreanos que
murieron en la guerra de korea van a
tener por fin un sepelio
desde el conflicto los restos de sus
cuerpos quedaron abandonados en la zona
prohibida entre las dos coreas
finalmente fueron encontrados e
identificados como 142 otros fantasmas
de la guerra que han encontrado una
tumba soldados desconocidos finalmente
reconocidos
[Música]
son verdaderos soldados y héroes para
corea sacrificaron lo más preciado que
tenían sus vidas por el país gracias a
ellos corea del sur es lo que hoy es en
día este año es el aniversario número 70
de la guerra de corea pero muchas
familias aún no han encontrado los
cuerpos de sus ancestros así que de
alguna manera la guerra aún no ha
terminado
otra vecina pero hay una chilena lan
[Música]
desde el final del conflicto en 1953 las
dos coreas no podían ponerse de acuerdo
para encontrar los cuerpos pero después
de un acuerdo con pyongyang hace dos
años el programa de investigación fue
revivido
la península coreana decidió desenterrar
ese pasado esa memoria de guerra es una
esperanza para las miles de familias de
las víctimas como en el caso de esta
mujer de 90 años de edad casada con uno
de esos héroes de guerra cuando tenía 19
años
[Música]
[Aplausos]
este es su hijo un huérfano de guerra
hijo del sargento kim cuya historia
vamos a relatar
[Música]
[Aplausos]
encontramos a esta familia en casa en la
parte sur de la península rechazaron
varias solicitud de entrevistas pero
aceptaron la de la televisión francesa
porque soldados franceses lucharon con
su antepasado
de este hombre que fue su marido hace 70
años lee bonh y tiene pocos pero
imperecederos recuerdos nunca se volvió
a casar
pero nada
sólo vivimos juntos un año ni siquiera
un año después de casarnos antes de que
lo enviarán al frente se fue al ejército
después de dejarme un hijo recibí muchas
cartas de él y como yo también podía
escribir nos escribimos mucho y de
repente no volví a saber nada
toda su vida mi suegra mantuvo este
cuadro colgado en la parte de su
dormitorio no dejaba de repetir el día
que me muera no me entierren en mi
pueblo natal
espaldas mis cenizas en la naturaleza
cuál es el punto de tener una tumba
completamente sola sin su padre
el sargento kim murió dos semanas antes
del armisticio su hijo tenía sólo dos
años
cuando tenía dos o tres años cada vez
que veía a un hombre pasar por nuestro
pueblo lo llamaba papá papá aunque
apenas podía hablar yo era un niño
inocente pero el corazón de mi madre se
rompía cuando veía eso
el año pasado la familia participó en la
campaña nacional encuentra a mi héroe
lanzada por el ejército surcoreano es
una cuchara desenterrada en un bosque en
la frontera entre las dos coreas que
llevó a la localización de los restos
del sargento kim junto a las iniciales
del ejército de eeuu el soldado había
grabado su nombre de los pocos
caracteres coreanos difíciles de leer
pero que significan mucho
si ve favor y vamos a mantener este
tesoro en nuestra familia para siempre
transmitiendo lo de generación en
generación
en lugar de lágrimas me sentí abrumado
por la alegría y el alivio llamé a todos
mis amigos y les dije encontré a mi
padre es tan raro encontrar a tu padre
cuando tienes 70 años
el sargento kim murió como resultado de
los bombardeos en lo que ahora es la de
mz la zona desmilitarizada que ha
separado a las dos coreas desde el final
de la guerra esa zona de amortiguación
es de hecho una de las más militarizadas
del mundo una tierra de alambre de púas
y selva custodiada por más de un millón
de soldados surcoreanos y norcoreanos
con una cantidad similar de minas en la
distancia corea del norte otro mundo a
sólo cuatro kilómetros de distancia
[Música]
este es el equipo surcoreano que busca
los restos de los veteranos en aquel
momento los cuerpos de 130 mil veteranos
soldados coreanos y extranjeros fueron
abandonados en los bosques y las
montañas
este es nuestro buscador de metales es
muy útil para encontrar artículos
militares
la guerra de korea ha sido
particularmente violenta murieron casi
un millón de soldados y dos millones de
civiles cada día estos hombres que
trabajan con el ejército desentierran
objetos de la guerra y de vez en cuando
restos humanos
y aún algún transferir creo winnender y
venta comida sin mire es una bala que
fue disparada por nuestro ejército
encontramos cucharas de plástico bolsas
de café y también miren este objeto está
escrito en inglés esta es la prueba de
que los estadounidenses lucharon y es
consistente con lo que los historiadores
han estado diciendo a veces durante seis
u ocho semanas no puedes encontrar nada
es un trabajo duro pero al final es por
una causa noble estamos muy orgullosos
cuando podemos devolver restos a una
familia de músicos
los investigadores también son
historiadores analizan las grandes
batallas de la guerra para determinar
las zonas a excavar en este bosque el
futuro de seúl se jugó en 1951 que fue
tomada por el norte y luego recuperada
por una coalición de 17 países liderada
por eeuu francia fue parte de ella siete
soldados de ese país siguen
desaparecidos
aquí hay restos de soldados desconocidos
por todas partes bajo nuestros pies
estas personas murieron en un país
extranjero sus cuerpos no pudieron ser
enviados a casa nuestro papel como
descendientes es devolver sus restos a
sus familias
este es el deber de nuestra unidad de
investigación nuestro ejército y nuestro
país
es un deber que corea del sur no había
cumplido después de la guerra el país
era pobre la prioridad era el desarrollo
económico su crecimiento récord la
convirtió en la undécima potencia del
mundo un eldorado tecnológico gracias a
los avances en el análisis de adn según
finalmente comenzó las excavaciones hace
20 años primero en corea del sur luego
desde 2019 en la zona fronteriza
una vez desenterrados los restos del
sargento kim fueron analizados en este
laboratorio del ministerio de defensa
para él fue muy rápido porque su hijo
había hecho un estudio genético la
familia estaba en la base de datos ahora
incluye 40.000 surcoreanos ansiosos por
encontrar a su antepasado
para dar una idea de la condición del
hueso que identificó a la familia era de
este tamaño es un recuerdo inolvidable
para mí
ya que tengo
los científicos surcoreanos tienen los
restos de 10.000 combatientes
encontrados en las excavaciones cráneos
huesos dientes sin embargo sólo una
pequeña parte de ella puede ser
rastreada hasta la composición genética
de una familia
si el adn de los descendientes ya está
registrado y los restos están en buenas
condiciones en resumen si todas las
condiciones son óptimas más la
identificación puede hacerse muy
rápidamente cada caso es muy diferente
algunos soldados son identificados
después de 12 años para otros toma un
año a veces incluso unos meses
y más allá del análisis genético los
científicos tamizan los objetos y la
ropa encontrados alrededor de los huesos
para determinar a qué batallón pudo
haber pertenecido el soldado cincuenta y
siete mil soldados involucrados en la
coalición de la onu han perecido tantas
pistas tantos ejércitos este botón es
típico de los uniformes del ejército de
eeuu y esto es una lata de cerveza
budweiser
para el sargento kim la cuchara supuso
una suerte extraordinaria como una
revelación una firma que ha sobrevivido
al paso del tiempo
15 fue un pequeño gesto de su parte
detallar su nombre para mostrar que era
suyo pero ese un pequeño gesto tuvo un
gran impacto en la identificación de los
restos
sanjuán
cuando únicas
y reunir a los muertos y a sus
descendientes los esfuerzos para acercar
a pyongyang y seúl también tienen como
objetivo reunir a las familias que aún
están vivas millones de coreanos fueron
separados de su hijo o hija padre o
madre hermano o hermana a causa de la
guerra un lado de la familia se
convirtió en norcoreano mientras que el
otro llevó una vida muy diferente en el
sur
en las 20 sesiones de reunión se han
organizado desde el 2000 unas pocas
horas conmovedoras para encontrarse
después de décadas de silencio
[Música]
en 2018 este surcoreano participó en una
de estas reuniones al igual que otros 88
afortunados sorteados por seúl después
de la guerra él y su madre se
encontraron en el lado sur mientras que
su padre y sus hermanas se convirtieron
en ciudadanos del norte durante 65 años
se prohibió toda comunicación su padre
murió pero libia un chan finalmente pudo
hablar con sus dos hermanas
he tenido mucha suerte es como atrapar
una estrella en el cielo una de mis
hermanas es profesora en un colegio
la otra es funcionaria lo que significa
que al menos tienen algo que comer es
algo de lo que vivir aunque no sepamos
exactamente cómo viven esa guerra no
solo ha destruido casa sino que también
ha separado familias y eso es una
verdadera lástima
desde ese fugaz encuentro todavía le es
imposible escribir o llamar a su familia
norcoreana todo lo que puede hacer como
miles de surcoreanos es dejar mensajes
en la alambrada de la frontera e
imaginar a sus hermanas al otro lado
mire dicen pronto nos reuniremos vemos
la alegría de los norcoreanos que se las
arreglan para escapar y llegar aquí
después de un complicado viaje por
supuesto pero en comparación con ellos
nuestro sufrimiento es mayor todo lo que
podemos hacer es quedarnos en corea del
sur llorando a los que hemos perdido no
es ira es como un resentimiento interno
una profunda pena no puedo culpar a
nadie
cuando los recuerdos vivos de la guerra
desaparezcan los lazos entre las dos
coreas seguirán siendo tan fuertes y tan
tenía grandes expectativas con los
esfuerzos de paz en 2018
con ese puente roto se llama el puente
sin retorno en los últimos años ha
habido encima de ese río movimientos de
vehículos a veces una o dos veces al día
porque las relaciones entre los dos
gobiernos estaban mejorando en esa
montaña cuando era niño la gente solía
ir de picnic allí
pero tras el fracaso de las
negociaciones con washington en 2019 la
frontera se ha convertido de nuevo en
una zona intransitable la oficina de
enlace en la que los funcionarios de los
dos países habían estado trabajando
juntos durante dos años no sólo fue
cerrada sino también destruida por
pyongyang un gesto beligerante que acaba
con el deshielo sin noticias del norte
sobre la cuestión de las excavaciones el
ejército surcoreano decidió continuar
solo investigando el pasado sin embargo
muchos de los restos de los soldados
olvidados están al otro lado del alambre
de púas
[Música]
bueno pues hasta aquí este boleto de
vuelta a la guerra de korea sites a ver
nuevamente este reportaje los invito a
visitar france24 puntocom
[Música]